the friends nation
welcome to the building
i'm gary vaynerchuk
the creator and ceo of the friends and
co-founder of vaynerchuck
the creator and ceo of the friends and
co-founder of every vaynerchuk creator
the creator and ceo of the friends and
co-founder of
creator the creator and ceo of being
friends and co-founder of everyday
creator the creator and ceo of bean
france and co-founder
of the creator and
all right i think i'm ceo now yeah
scared dustin
sorry
there's a lot of echoing like you can't
hear me am i not like i'm good all right
all right little rusty you know what do
you want from me just a little little
rusty
uh and that's okay
john why don't you a lot more people
here won't know who you are
um i also really like that you're
sitting in this lower chair making me
seem like i'm towering over you
um why don't you tell everybody who you
are
before you do that john uh
we're here to taste the newest uh
collaboration between empathy wines and
uh v friends we had a
magnificent launch last holiday season
on black friday i believe for empathy
elephant
today we've got the meerkat we want to
make the best white wine we'll get into
that and all that let's touch on say
hello um excited about it awesome hey
everybody uh
for the 99 of you that don't know who i
am i am john troutman
uh gary's co-founder in empathy wines um
started the brand with kind of like one
mission
empathy for the consumer empathy for the
farmer so for the consumer we want to
make the
very best wine possible for the price
point
uh by delivering outsized value and for
the farmer we work with
top growers primarily in california but
really with a mission statement of all
the best growers around the world in
order to tell their stories and
ultimately get their wine in your
glasses so you can appreciate it so
we've now this is our fourth vintage so
we've been doing it for a little while
and
this is our second wine collaborated
with v friends so super excited to get
into it and tell you a little bit more
so we're opening up sales um in this
limited window starting right now let's
get the url there dustin i don't know if
you've created like a garyvee.com url
for the page but let's let's uh get the
community to share the link
you did nice dust um
this is the first time we're tasting it
first time i'm tasting it finished we
obviously tasted it along the way
we've probably tasted this exact wine
obviously because we need to but this is
the first time with the actual label on
it
uh we have three tiers of it unlike the
empathy uh cabernet we also added the
limited edition t-shirt because swag has
obviously oh what i forgot about this
part
the little i like that swag is obviously
a big deal big deal we thought that a
lot of people would buy the two bottle
set how much is the two bottle set
hundred bucks
okay so then we definitely didn't think
that um i was gonna say we thought
people could buy the two bottle set and
just basically buy for the t-shirt but i
don't think a hundred dollar t-shirt is
the right move on earth especially with
a pending recession a couple things
empathy elephant is such a big character
in our world it was the height of
collectibility land in nft and i know
people have done extremely well
uh flipping the empathy elephant empty
bottles actual models what we set out to
do with this collaboration was how do we
make the best kind of fifty dollar
sixty dollar seven dollar white wine
what great for idol would that be
work backwards john obviously since we
sold empathy to consolation you and nate
our other partner went over and have
worked the constellation for many years
why don't we talk about this wine from a
wine nerd perspective which you are
and kind of our mission at it but for
everybody who's watching
um we really uh wanted to create
a fun experience here where it's either
what are the sets two there's ten and
then what's the middle one five five so
two five and ten bottle lots uh dustin
you wanna put up the url where people
can find this as we get into it uh
because we're gonna have this little
window and we're gonna close it and then
the wine will be gone
uh garyvee.com
to the moon muscat
and that will take you to the landing
page on empathy that is now officially
open
uh please community members in linkedin
discord all the places please share that
url once you get to the page uh so we
can have it and um i'm just really
excited to be with all of you once you
talk a little bit about the wines
and the sets cool
um so from a wine perspective this was
actually a ton of fun because
wu scott's a great variety that i think
a lot of people don't understand that
much in that it's the same grape that's
used in moscato so
you know you see a lot of that at 10 12
15 bucks a bottle
semi-sparkling sweet for the most part a
lot of them i would say aren't the
greatest of quality it's a lot of
marketing they're not not good quality
um
for us it was how do we interpret that
same grapefruit oh okay i apologize to
drop dustin is the
is the url cap
sensitive
yes
i could lower i'll lower case it right
now
a garyvee.com
moon
sure
can you pop it up when you're done with
that
because this [ __ ] that you came up
with is completely impossible
oops
i'm kidding
i love it go ahead
so this is basically an interpretation
of that grape but at a very very high
quality so
for those that are a little bit more
into wine you're familiar napa valley
home of a lot of the most prestigious
wines in the world definitely in the
united states
this is from a top vineyard in the napa
valley within stagsley district so
farmed very very seriously farmed
organically um
you basically took what is otherwise
known as primarily known as a grape
variety for inexpensive wine and
flipped the script and super premium
yeah yep yeah i mean i think
what i knew is that there's so many
people in the bee friends world
that are looking for amazing ways to
attach what the brand the journey
the fun we're having and you know
what
what i also i'm always trying to do is
not create things you're buying for the
sake of buying but they're bringing you
value in return and so
knowing that a lot of you will buy
there we go dustin knowing that a lot of
you will buy
white wine
in
july august and september
and knowing that a lot of you will buy
wine at 10 15 and 20. so this is a
little bit elevated up
right um
and
and then
but also knowing people spend 40 and 50
and this will be elevated down with the
t-shirt with the wine we wanted to
create something that's why we put the
t-shirt in this time it's just like
being part of the universe at 100 bucks
with high quality where we over deliver
on the core thing of the wine
where the wine's over delivering on the
price the t-shirt's free and it's fun
it's just like like good
good you know like
the heck garyvee.com go ahead try to
keep talking
uh
i don't want to like oversell this but
this one's way better than the last time
we even tasted it too okay there we go i
think it's really good now that it's
been bottled except cookies you think so
yeah i'm a little flustered actually
it's so good
you like it yeah
i uh i think it goes great with thai
food i need like type like
nate is hitting the team sitting there
we aren't planning to close the sales
soon enough we got it so
you know i want to over communicate as
we're talking behind the scenes
i
i think that we're keeping it open
i think that
there's i don't want everybody to rush
as like this is limited
but it's very limited and
we've got a window where we're opening
it and then we've gotta decide what's if
there's any left
what i'm most excited about is how over
the top the deal is from the wine
standpoint
with the t-shirt so got it got it we're
keeping it for the summer got it i'm
just
it'll be interesting like people can
reorder it if they love it
i love i love this so so
two bottles a hundred
right
once
five bucks two bottles a hundred five
bottles of 175 yep
and then yeah
and then 10 bottles at 315 with uh two
bottles a hundred five bottles 175 all
right everybody should buy five models
um that's interesting
i like that you guys did that you so you
were really incentivizing the vibe yeah
you got it yeah shipping costs a lot of
money that's true so you're getting
killed there got it i would go with the
five
or the ten if you're drinking white wine
10 3 15 31 bucks yeah if you're buying
20 to 50 white wine 20 because at 31
it's so much better than what you're
buying at 20 it's worth going there so
if you're buying between 20 and 50
white wine this summer
and you're gonna buy a case at the
liquor store at wine library at
you at
albertson's bevmo
at
total wine
specs
this is like buy the 10 pack
is if you're gonna buy a case of 20 to
50 wine
love it
god this smells
i want to do q a
so dustin make sure you're reading the
questions
and uh jump in with questions randomly
during dead spots okay dust
good
uh if you're just joining us we're
unveiling first taste of the empathy
wines
to the moon
uh meerkat muscat toe 20 21 napa valley
and yes regina we are about to talk
about the wine here we go let's do a
snippy snip
you know the thing that's really
interesting is even when i was talking
and it was funny i was trying to look at
logistics and you were talking about
this wine's better the aromatics are
really starting to come together i get
like an acacia white flower a little bit
of a melon
um
like kind of like green melon and a hint
of like white peach you know and a
little bit of mango thoughts
i thought you're gonna say white pepper
oh are you getting white pepper too but
i get all those things too you know
what's funny the acacia flower i've
always used as an inner chamber yeah
one thing brandon at wine library told
me about
the other day that really caught my
attention is
sansair's ungettable
low crop the last three four years
brand's like literally i can't buy
shitty sunser
and sell it for 30. can't find it yeah
which gets me excited because this is
when
wines like this
like a premium muscat hit the radar like
what's definitely going to happen is a
lot of you are going to buy this wine
for the swag so don't forget it comes
with this
tea
um i'll put an eyebrows
um
and you're going to drink the wine
you're buying the wine for part of the
journey
you
trust us and you tasted the anybody who
tasted the empathy cabernet as another
fact in the comments did you taste the
empathy cabernet empathy elephant
and what did you think watch this
so anybody who did that is gonna buy two
five or ten right now
because of what they saw happen with
their cabernet which you now know
that this is like a ludicrous deal
and it's obviously such a
low price it's summer
most people do go under 30 on white so
it's a premium white so i'm empathetic
to them but the swag
but then they're going to taste the wine
and then they're going gonna be in
trouble because they're gonna fall in
love with scott and they're gonna have
to find like weird alsatian like to get
right right but it's gonna replace a lot
of people's sauvignon blanc pinot grigio
and they're drinking thoughts
i agree
completely
i also think this is it's funny when i
first tasted it again here hey dustin
two things keep the url to buy because
we are in full
this is the moment we're doing because
we may shut it down we don't have that
many cases it could happen today
um
but when you have a question dust jump
in because everyone loves seeing your
face on this stream and just throw some
stuff at me go ahead
i i think this is a good white wine for
somebody who doesn't drink white wine
because a little bit of that
the fruit is so pronounced it's not
sweet wine
but it makes people that struggle with
wine like it
because it's so
delicious and drinkable yup yup that's
exactly right and even somebody who's uh
maybe
doesn't check
we're sorry no international shipping i
apologize yeah just trying to do
logistics
wine is tough as a matter of fact i said
in the discord today
you know vitamins wine we've been doing
a lot of collaborations that have legal
issues
to
outside the u.s we're going to make sure
that more of the items going forward are
global
obviously because we know um
that's important also yes there are
states we can't ship to ironically new
jersey being one of them but ship these
to your friends like new jersey people
have pennsylvania and new york um liquor
laws in america are just like super
tough i'm sorry scott there is a dark
horse chance that if we don't sell out
i'm trying to like work with empathy and
my dad and be like the great bridge
maker of like send the rest to my
library so there's that's looming but
i'm not making that promise
um
go ahead my friend
somebody asked earlier how long could
you open this and keep it in your fridge
and then drink it again
what do you think what are your thoughts
on that two days two days yeah real
quick i want to do an entrepreneurial
question
um something some 15 year old asked
something by the way notice how many
people are going nuts about the empathy
cabernet here
what should a 15 year old invest into
with little income lenny
buying things at garage sales and thrift
stores
and reselling them on ebay and amazon
with a little bag you can't be in
investment mode you have to be in
operational execution mode so with a
thousand bucks you have to go buy a
thousand dollars at a garage sale and
turn into 2 900
take that same 2900 with what you're
learning go to thrift stores dollar
stores garage sales take that to 7 000 7
to fourteen that's what i did literally
i'm giving you the advice i did and
still reel i mean garage sale flipping
is out of control i'm dying to do a new
episode of trash talk it's been hard but
there's that big shout out to sal who i
love sal the tiger he got a five pack
who got a five pack who just ordered a
five pack let's put up uh the url if you
want to buy in this
pre-launch i'm not pretty much in the
opening day launch uh
garyvee.com dustin must have went and
took a poop because he hasn't switched
this bottom yet there it is
listen uh garyvee.com if you want to buy
one if you bought a five pack just reply
with a five because that's what i want
to see i want to see the five packs go
heavy nice two pack from aaron want to
see who got a 10 pack actually two five
or ten if you bought one right now just
because i want to go back and play a
little bit after this recording and
watch it
if you bought
the new empathy
uh
white collaboration moscato meerkat v
friends empathy with free t-shirt
uh
please put in two five or ten based on
what you bought i just want to get a
sense of what's happening here before we
get out dust i want to pound people with
i want to put do you ship to hawaii
you can't ship this to y no yeah
some weird laws with merch any
recommendations of starting mma yeah
josh just make stuff
dustin i'm struggling with you putting
it down there yes i need you to come on
like this okay
cool
i'm going to sift through still there's
a lot of comments coming in or questions
what's up
only come on with questions bye
i love him um do two five packs
interesting oh go get him please uh
garyvee.com moon if you are buying
today's meerkat white
uh
two pack five pack ten pack you can see
the pricing there super excited about
this um please fire away your business
questions or your wine questions
dustin's gonna go super rapid fire jump
in a bunch of times how many cases i
think we did 800 or less right you know
800 800 cases of this wine were made we
wanted we we're going to go 2 000 but we
wanted to keep super high premium
quality and so like
that's where i was saying the discord
and today like this one isn't a money
maker this one isn't a flipper collector
thing on your end unless you drink it
see me at v-con and i sign it and i go
on to doing what i'm supposed to do and
then 20 years you flip it this is oh
this is just better white wine than i
would have bought at ralph's or specs or
wine library or somewhere else plus i
get the free t-shirt and like there's a
lot of clever people like somebody
already just texted me and said yeah
cool but i'm going to sell the t-shirt
for 40 get the wine for and it's like
watching all of you with uno or the or
the zero i mean what's going on with
zero cool cards right now for series two
like you see it andrew like people are
literally getting a buck they paid a
thousand for the nft they buy a box they
open i'll be right with you dust they
open a box get a high-end card sell it
for like the whole thing's just wild
dust
danielle asked do you think today's
environment isn't a good place to open
up a retail
entertainment business i.e bowling alley
pool hall arcade etc daniel i'm going to
give you a tremendous answer to this
question uh one that i want the team to
split and put on tick tock and instagram
there is never a bad time to open a
great business
and there is never a good time to open a
shitty business yes we're heading into a
recession potentially but if you're a
great operator wine library when i took
over recession exploded it me and aj
started vaynermedia recession it micro
recession exploded it
like if you're a good enough operator
it's always a good time to open a
business if you're passionate and
understand what to do and if you're not
a good operator we could be in frothy
frothy land like we were the last decade
and you will lose i watched tons of
businesses go out of business five years
ago when it was easy as [ __ ]
martin asked is it a limited release
yes there's only 800 cases most of which
are selling out as we speak looking at
the numbers getting the texts
um
not to create hysteria i think you've
got time into tomorrow if you're
watching this in the morning maybe not i
have no idea it depends on how it's
flowing it seems to be really flowing um
and then it will never be made again
um let's talk a little more about the
wine so that we mix in wine talk with
dustin's business and other questions
what else you got to say about this wine
what else about
i think a lot of people just drink what
they know like you were saying sansai or
pinot grigio chardonnay this is a grape
that just forces you to drink something
different and realize that
a weight i actually might be overpaying
for those things too so yeah you know
it's funny you say that right like when
i drink wines like this i really i had a
75
white burgundy
a week ago
in my apartment
that sucked yeah then i was like is this
like you know like i'm in a funny part
where like i'm getting caught sometimes
because the wineries and producers that
i loved in the past i'm like in this
journey where i'm like randomly picking
up stuff hanging brandon send me stuff
and even like people sending me bottles
this was sent as a gift
i was pumped
it was terrible
it was and when i see terrible our talk
it was just boring right like cool
thanks for this i've had this like i
could have like poured myself a glass of
water put some cucumber and lemon in it
and this is what it would have been 75
bucks
because it has the brand yep and so
what's fun about making a wine like this
and what i think we ended up here i
don't think we were going here we
started this journey me you need
i think that we got here and then i
think we got here
because the north star was when we do
the summer version of this successful
empathy elephant cab
let's over deliver so everybody buys it
and drinks it right and by the way if
you're buying this big shout out i've
got a fun thing for all of us this is
gonna make some influencers buy this if
you buy this and you post a video of you
drinking this
uh on instagram and twitter and tag me i
will share a ton in my stories in the
next two weeks of people just drinking
this and reviewing it pro and con you
might not like it and that's a big part
of it
yeah you know what i mean yeah do you i
mean that was like the mission behind
wine library in many ways wide library
tv i should say was getting people to
try it was your thing
here we are actually
that's what he got for us
brian jones asked if you are in love
with multiple
things that make you happy how do you
pick one
flipping a coin
doesn't get in here
yeah just think like if that's true
you're lucky that's literally what i do
now if i can't even decide on a
restaurant i'm like all right heads or
tails here we go
good flip that's what i do i flip a coin
mentally i'm like i'm gonna do this like
like the questions are confusing because
people are actually asking which one
will make me more money
because and i'm saying [ __ ] the money
you just want to be happy you like them
all you've won and you'll never know
what would happen
you just never know so flip a coin
you've already won if everything makes
you happy just pick one people like to
dance around and play with [ __ ] i don't
know like they like the mockery of the
indecisiveness it's almost like the
self-deprecating kind of like drama
thing they like to talk to their mom and
sister about like [ __ ] pick one and
go
a lot of people seem upset about
flipping a coin
what the [ __ ] i'm like listen to the
question i like multiple things nobody
really knows the outcome like it could
look right on paper that you're gonna
make more money and be happier with this
one but then something changes the next
day you make people quit their job to go
into nfts
and now they're worried because they
just thought it was a gold rush and it's
not a gold rush everything's hard
everything is twists and turns and then
you know my favorite thing dustin andrew
because you look at my content all day
let's say you picked the right thing it
was the laundromat not the wine business
and it was right you did 10 times more
business but on this day when you went
to the laundry store to [ __ ] open the
store a bus killed you and if you did
the [ __ ] wine thing you would have
made 20 less money but you would have
lived to 92. life's [ __ ]
unpredictable
there is no right [ __ ] answer
at the time there's only a right answer
when you go to heaven and then it's not
so right
all the time either [ __ ] what are we
trying to solve for
right
thank you
i'm on fire i'm feeling tight clip that
[ __ ] up what else you got
bradley graham asked do you feel all
platforms will start moving towards
interest-based platforms as we develop i
think he means what tick-tock is doing
around the interest graph i do think
bradley that that will be a challenge
because the social graph i follow andrew
we were best friends in high school we
lose touch
in college we definitely lose touch post
college we both loved [ __ ] prank
calling at 16 and now he's in my feed
talking about fishing and i'm into
industrial like corporate building i'm
not as interested in android anymore
thus might be not valuable
tick tock says you like chocolate today
i'm going to give you chocolate you like
wine you got into football that's why
we're so sticky and enjoying it so yes
i've always thought the intra scrap was
bigger than the social wrap which is why
i made a terrible claim to aj that
tumblr which was the one of the three
companies that i invested in facebook
twitter tumblr in my opening
realm of being an investor was going to
be the biggest of the three because i
thought the interest crap was the
biggest of the three i think i ended up
being right it was that mark zuckerberg
was and that williams were better
operators than david carp even though
all three are phenomenal david carp sold
tumblr for a billion dollars to yahoo so
they all were remarkable
i've learned those lessons the last 20
years but yes i think the interest crap
is a big ass deal
all right one more time if you are
trying to buy the new collab
uh ooh somebody said is it vegan
friendly
you were telling me before we went
online this says is predominantly
organic break it down predominantly
organic so
source from
majority napa valley vineyards which
were farmed organically
sustainably
so like really putting an emphasis on
sustainability and winemaking
in terms of vegan i'm i don't want to
speak absurd i don't want to find out i
don't think it is yeah so
some of our other empathy wines are so
interesting i'm sorry yeah this one
might be uh but we got to do our fact we
got to do our homework so you'll tweet
that out from the empathy handle
tomorrow yep or tonight yep or they
might do that right now if they're
watching let me check and see if you can
get that info now
team if you're just joining us uh we are
on youtube live and linkedin and other
places
live talking about our new collaboration
the empathy wines white wine
collaboration with beef friends and
specifically with the to the moon
meerkat
this is the 2021
napa valley premium dry muscat we have a
two pack a five pack and a ten pack that
comes with the limited edition swag
t-shirt that trouty is modeling
and uh we're really excited about it if
you'd like to buy it
in this limited release uh only 800
cases are made garyvee.com
moon
uh lowercase moon uh make sure to get it
there we'll get you right there and uh
i'm really uh excited i really hope you
try it if you are buying a 20 to 50 wine
this summer
including two bottles but definitely
five bottles because that's where the
pricing you guys really created an
extreme there yeah the two bottles are
50 bucks a pop with the free t-shirt it
advertises it's obviously like 35 30.
the five is 25 bucks yeah we wanted to
reward people who bought more because of
the five yeah
i like that
so yes please check it out
tails never fails
good
how do you cameron abs how do you learn
how to be a good operator
uh i think you are either born with
natural talent
or you are taught on the job i think
it's you can also learn it in a book a
little bit but then you have to you can
learn how to do the right exercises and
then you have to execute it's all
execution trout why don't you speak to
it why don't you tell everybody a three
minute a very fast three-minute version
of our story together because it's
inspiring for a lot of youngsters that
are trying to replicate what you did
with me yeah and then because you were
so close to my operating you were in the
office of nice you were a chief of staff
and that office ceo for me
you
had been very close to a lot of stuff
why don't you i think you could actually
bring more value to me yeah so the short
story of mine was i was very passionate
about wine
uh knew i wanted to go into the industry
started studying reading textbooks
went to youtube to learn about it
discovered this guy over here
uh went down a rabbit hole and realized
that not only is he a great uh
wine educator but also was a great
marketer reached out to him and said hey
i'd love to get close with you and learn
a little bit from you if there are any
job opportunities let me know i think i
got like
a
three-word tweet reply meet somebody and
long story short i that was about 12
years ago i moved to new york city
started working for gary in the wine
industry later at vayner media then
again in the wine industry at empty
wines um
so for me are you being up close to me
and you know as an operator robert
hanson great operator consolation like
let's start with me since it was first
and then allison and you know
what did you in hindsight now now that
you've got some gray hairs yep good
you're looking good i know why do you
think
um
uh i'm thinking about getting an afro
implant like like just like literally
like going to turkey and just getting
like let it go like yeah just be like
phil toronto he inspired me um
what do you think you've learned that's
most unique that they won't think like
what was most unique
so a couple i think i'm sure people ask
you all the time like what's gary like
or you get a little right i think
a couple things i think it's nature and
nurture i think certain people are just
born
leaders and are able to kind of know how
to run a business and then other people
need to be conditioned and grow and be
exposed to how to do it
i also think there's different ways to
run different types of businesses where
like
certain people that went to mba programs
and then go up the corporate ladder are
really good at running publicly traded
companies p l yeah make decisions for
today's profit yep and that's not my
style no
and i think there are other people who
are more entrepreneurial and can figure
out how to take a dime and turn it into
a dollar right and
can do that in any vertical no matter
what it is they're not specialists in a
certain category they kind of can just
figure it out right
what else teach that
what's like what's the coolest move you
ever saw me do that you thought was
stupid
that then turned out to be smart that's
like a fun story you don't have to use
names of employees because i'm sure it
has to do with that give me that if i
said what's the thing that you left this
office and said
you're a [ __ ] that like i know gary's
brilliant but this is stupid or like how
do we get him not to do this we then did
it as an organization and it crushed and
you're like why
oh my god
funny i mean
kinda answering your question funny
story we named our llc
goose egg llc and the reason was is
because gary used to say that he was
trying to run all of his businesses with
goose egg profit and which makes no
sense right like like why would you want
to make no profit and the idea being
i'm going to continually reinvest into
my business continue to grow and
aka my people people
in order to
not
take advantage of the short-term
economics but with the idea being it'll
pay off in the long term
so which is a very different way of
running companies than i think a lot of
people think about it out of curiosity
why do you go for a 10 pack
instead of a case i guess he's asking oh
no somebody bought two five packs i
guess he gets two t-shirts why didn't we
do 12 bottle packs no sal said picked up
two five packs and then somebody ross
brown said why'd you buy instead of
10-pack because sal decided the t-shirt
was worth it because he got two t-shirts
probably right i'm answering for you sal
i have no idea um
and so go ahead so back to the goose egg
i want to actually hear that so i just
think it's by the way before you answer
that if you are buying
the meerkat
white wine go to
garyvee.commoonalllowercase
and if you bought it just now
reply with a two five or ten
a two five or ten in here
and also i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna actually up the ante
series one so as you guys know the cards
have gotten hot we've got the original
ones
we got the unos where the gary vee's hot
and now we have series two
which i saw beautiful
series you know compete and collect
if you buy today i'm gonna go i'm gonna
ask empathy to go to the database and
i'm gonna pick one of you randomly
and i'm gonna send you a premium zero
cool series one because i'm going to the
national
and i'm gonna have to buy one rips if
you're watching
i need you to keep me honest in this
video
i'm going to pick one random person that
buys wine during the next
15 minutes meaning at any point prior
yesterday because you saw it during this
stream or anybody that does it before we
get out of here at 8 45 or whenever i
get out of here if you place an order on
empathy wines right now garyvee.com
it'll send you there if you place an
order right now before we get out i'm
gonna pick one of you randomly look at
your address and randomly send you a
super premium zero cool meerkat card
uh maybe it's an auto maybe it's a spec
maybe it's an epic one of two i'm gonna
find one in the next two weeks
and i'm gonna send one to one of the
people that randomly bought one right
now just to make it fun just to like add
to the ante for somebody who was like
teetering like should i buy two or five
or ten i do drink white wine it sounds
good
you know just a thousand dollar
collectible card also by the way while
i've got you sunday i am in los angeles
if you don't know what i'm talking about
go to just go to garyvee.com discord get
the information i'm gonna be at cool
kicks in los angeles i put it everywhere
on my socials um
please come los angeles if you're there
come say what's up i'm gonna be signing
the
flex and fox toy that we did a limited
edition with them for 500 units and then
next week wednesday thursday friday
atlantic city the national sports card
show i'm bringing my lebrons i'm
bringing my kareem abdul-jabbar's i'm
bringing my v friends my marvels my
pokemons i'm a dealer wednesday thursday
friday of next week come through to that
garyvee.com discord
you've got to live in discord if you're
watching this right now and you're not
part of our discord huge mistake there
it is
get in that's where all the alpha is
that's where all the information is i
can't wait to see all of you uh and uh
sal you don't need a flexing fox to go
to the event in la
you need a flexing fox to get front in
line and kind of get hooked up but
everybody can show up to la
uh and so that's that justin smith thank
you for the two pack order all right
back to you can go back to the meerkat
stuff
break down so you feel like you thought
i was stupid for not making money
i didn't think you were stupid you were
just yeah you didn't know why i did that
you used to tell clients that you ran a
business that was not profitable and
they got very confused yeah you didn't
make money for three years it's true
that's why v friends is fun for me to
operate right now people like oh the
market's down this and that i don't like
you doing this i don't like you doing
that i don't like you doing this i'm
like jesus christ if these people
understood for three years vayner didn't
make a single dollar but now today
is the most important agency in the
world
like wait till they see what i do with v
friends like i understand you might not
be happy with me hour to hour
but i know what i'm doing
you should buy more you should buy more
be friends series two
do you have a series two beatrice how
many just one you should buy another one
you have 700 bucks dustin
you have 10 series 2b friends i paid at
a premium price too
get over here right now get into come
here
how many do you have don't lie
what i'm you in the face
get over here what you move
you want but i appreciate the support
i'm gonna come through for you
you watch stick with me kim all right
all right
um everyone's like oh you selling yours
now
no we're gonna [ __ ] dump
people are so long you know when people
sold a week ago when they were a
thousand
ethereum but now it's 1500 people are
confused you see punks a month ago
versus today people don't understand
people are impatient people are like
caring about their money right now
people spend money they couldn't afford
to lose that was rule number one do not
spend
one dollar you can't afford to lose thus
you don't have to panic sell
did anybody learn that lesson this year
you you know listen you're grinding
la girlfriend like you you've got to
manage your money and you should still
buy one at seven you
[ __ ]
you better buy something i wouldn't i
learned that lesson too though i know
i need to flip some stuff in order you
have seven hundred dollars yeah buy a
series
trust me i'm about to get hot
and i'm doing this publicly so everybody
see the
you tell your friends i'm doing it live
on [ __ ] ustream right now q stream
youtube stream i know oh gee flip cam
flip cam
guys my flip cam is ripping
um
all right
this is fun i don't even want this to
end uh because i know oh dustin please
oh okay
brandy sickles ass i'm pursuing coaching
now and i struggle with pitching without
experience is it just practice until it
hits
yes and brandy it's not being scared to
lose the reason i'm undefeated in
business is i like losing more than
winning thus i'm not scared in the pitch
because the scariest thing in the pitch
is to lose and if you're not scared of
that well then you've won
that's it
there's nothing i was saying what you
lost a pitch who gives a [ __ ] it's a
funny psychology though it's the same
thing as like going up to a girl in a
bar everyone's afraid i'm not as
confident in that environment i was not
as confident of going up to a girl in
high school college post-college as i am
in business which is actually why i
understand the dynamic so well i
understand you're scared
because i was less confident doing that
than i was in business where i had 100
confidence i only had
80 confidence in the other game and so i
know what that by the way that delta
between 80 and 100 was [ __ ]
catastrophic
i left so many wins on the board out of
fear and so are so many people here that
are scared to lose the pitch just be
authentic be yourself
is it sold out looks like somebody just
said sold out we might be sold out
i don't think so whoa it sounds like
five packs already sold out
can you confirm that
[ __ ]
10 packs are about to explode if that's
true
let's go daniel big 10 bottle purchase
to get the t-shirt is the team what's
the team saying
five packs were done for me i love that
yeah the website says sold out
wow
all
no just a five five bottle
the ten bottle packs are about to go
crazy the two bottles still available
yeah yeah that's like the less best deal
but actually like how much do we sell
befriend t-shirts for 40
i think so
right so then you're down to 20 a pop is
there shipping on top of 100 built-in
free shipping yeah
i was razzing two packs a little bit too
much
like a low cost eventually to get the
tea right
interesting
this wine is [ __ ] amazing delicious
like like literally like just back to
like if you love champagne and sansair
and chablis like for a lot of the
hardcore subways in new york it just
might have too much
sweetness in the fruit
but for 99.9 of the people watching this
it's like gonna crush yeah it's it's
like conundrum have any of you drank
it used to be called chemist conundrum
now it's conundrum have any of you drank
conundrum white
please reply if you have buy a 10 pack
right now
if you bought conundrum white
or triana white get a 10 pack right now
promise
um i just talked to tyler and he had be
friends and he was right only the small
size t-shirt is sold out medium
large
with a small that sold out yeah that's
all right the fives are back
got it so five pack with small t-shirt
out
that's cool yeah
um
john this is fun
i miss
i'm bringing back tea with garyvee i
think and v what's happening
but i'm like vodka which is funny
because i'm russian but i can do tea
with garyvee as tequila because i do
like steel
you like that one dustin yeah i'm a big
tequila fan now so that'll be fun listen
we can eat
garyvee in the morning but if i do it at
night it's cool with garyvee just a t
yeah heal a logo that'd be really fun
tea with garyvee morning night
night again i endorse it
oh man by the way big shout out to manu
john
uh big big caps don't you can put this
up here dustin don't trust gary he only
plays people
john as somebody who's known me for
13 years and like knows everything's
been in my inbox who i am as a human
being
like this happens occasionally that's
what happens with high profile like
through the world and you've heard this
like you've heard this your whole career
less now because i've done enough
but when you see people like manu john
who hide behind
and a fake name would love to know your
real name john
um
how much does that make you laugh when
it's so hard the other way like like
break that down as somebody who's been
close to
somebody who puts themselves out there
it's funny when i first started working
with you i'd get like emotionally upset
about it like it would like hurt my
feelings yeah boy i only knew and now
i'm just like
people just need that
really get exposed and understand that
like you're correct which is why which
is why i have empathy for manu like
i'm a high energy guy gift of gab tons
of charisma
good looking
like i'm just kidding i'm kidding but
tons of charisma
oh man of john manner john thank you
brother uh so there's i love that name i
love manu
i love that name yeah i've always loved
that name i actually liked manning
ginobili a little bit more than i needed
to just because i loved the name manu
i think it has a lot to do with the fact
that i love argentina
and malbecs and the people like i
actually think universally every man who
i've met i love including man of john i
understand what he's doing in there yeah
man doesn't know me right i mean he
doesn't [ __ ] know me at all i've
never met man of john winner spent four
hours he doesn't look in my inbox he
doesn't know me the way all of you know
um
which is you know
right you know people won't even know
what played them but man who knows
you know they don't know but man who you
know
it's [ __ ] cynicism and lack of
information it's her inside i have a lot
of compassion for amanda john and others
that go down that path which is why i
have learned to like like in sports i'll
do that i'm like [ __ ] tom brady but it's
not real but in real life judging
people's character without knowing a
single thing
is funny to me and then hear say the
amount of [ __ ] i hear of like you did
this i sure didn't
like i'm glad your friend rick who's
unhappy is trying to tear down which is
why you know me i've become completely
numb to i watch what i've done in the
last three years based on what you just
said similar is when people talk [ __ ]
about people i know
that are successful
maverick carter
lebron's partner oh he's only cause
okay cool but i've seen maverick work
his [ __ ] ass off for 15 years and i'm
glad that you say that he's got that
because lebron but i think lebron's got
what he's got off the court because of
maverick
you know what i mean yep that [ __ ] i'm
sure you guys felt this when you guys
became my partner you went from intern
to partner
sure there was some stuff but i like
they didn't see the eight
years of us bleeding at two in the
morning working on [ __ ] that earned you
this spot to be my partner yeah yeah
same idea yeah
anyway fun stuff lots of interesting
talks we're wrapping up here soon we're
going to be selling out pretty shortly
if you're interested in the empathy
white wine garyvee.com
um when i say sell out shortly let me
rephrase that we're going to be coming
off here now
we've sold a bunch
it will still linger on the website so
go check it out there'll be a closing
period which i'm empathy is going to
decide when
um but if you were a drinker of twenty
to fifty dollar wine this is absolutely
time to buy garyvee.com buy a two five
or ten pack get the free t-shirt get
ridiculous wine for the value in return
almost all of you buy wine that's not as
good at the price point if you're a ten
to twenty dollar bottle of wine this
buyer this is a good thing to splurge
for so many of you are buying 40
t-shirts of defense that means you're
paying 30 on the whites you get into the
5 and 10 pack it gets really ridiculous
you went to 25 dollars a bottle in the
five pack well we haven't really talked
about the 10 bottle pack with the tank
top that comes with it i didn't well i'm
undereducated this is your program top
yes so the 10 bottle pack is the only
one where you get access to the tank top
it's a tank top instead of a regular
t-shirt it's a 10 bottle pack t-shirt
and a tank and a tank okay you did a
terrible job yeah that was a bad job by
me yeah i saved it for the end
yeah most people left by now you like
really are a bad retailer
is that okay ah i could have scrolled
down right this is [ __ ] awesome the
ten pack comes with the [ __ ] tank and
the tanks the attack at the tank is
[ __ ] awesome the tag is so gangster
so 315 so you're paying 31.50 for the
[ __ ] wine forty dollars thirty
dollars for a tank thanks the same price
for more or less than two years a little
less so let's go 40 mt 30 on the tank
right so that's 70 down to two which
also like because the only way to get
the tank is
it's gonna through the
there's so many gangsters i love when i
was at v-con and i've got the national
and i've got la though i don't think
this will get into people's hands before
la but i'm alluding to a lot of things
and be like i'm gonna be out and about
for a while here for be friends holders
watching people
arb
play flip life against my world is my
favorite
like they buy the 10-pack because the
tank then i'm at like v-con next year
like can you sign this and i'm like i
signed the tank and i'm already like
they're going to sell this for 100 bucks
on ebay it's [ __ ] amazing
it's my favorite anyway uh i see big uh
big uh big pips 3051 says sorry i'm late
let me recap as we run out here
um
we've been tasting the newest white wine
collaboration with empathy wines and v
friends called the to the moon meerkat
from empathy wines uh there's a two and
five and ten pack you can get there by
going to
um
actually bought
actually gary v doc actually bought
i actually bought three pack went back
and got a five weird there's not maybe a
two pack okay anyway
um if you want to buy the wine
go to
garyvee.com moon lowercase moon
buy a two five or ten pack
like our homie zack storm crypto just
put in the comments that he bought a 10
pack if you bought one please put it in
i'm gonna wrap up now if you buy one
here before 9 pm eastern so you got 13
minutes if you buy one
of the sets in the next 13 minutes i'm
also going to randomly pick one person
next week when i'm at the national i'm
gonna find on ebay or at the national a
super premium series one zero cool
meerkat card super premium so like a
spec or an epic will be the lowest
you'll get i gotta find it first an epic
an auto a spec i'll get a super premium
one which is like a lot of colors if you
do the homework i'm gonna send one of
you that that bought today during this
time i know this is gonna be saved
i know a lot of you are watching this on
thursday and i'm gonna go to the site
and hopefully there's still some stuff
available to buy
i'm really excited i hope you uh
to me this is less of like you should
buy this this is more of like if you
drink white wine you should you should
consider this because it's better than
what you're buying
um
parting thoughts trail
uh
thank you everyone if you got this far i
hope everyone got the tank is that 10
pack
i love that
um no this was this was a ton of fun i
don't have the mirror
no
it's not a fox
no this is the legendary lemur
oh actually
trap where's the go grab that humongous
sign people have to see this
final uh thoughts on the card market
going to nashville pretty excited about
a mat much like the crypto market nft
market it's mature people are more
thoughtful buying the smart stuff i just
bought two jordan rookie psa tens
how cool is this
[ __ ] rad
i'm obsessed with this little what watch
this just oh hold on
what how does that work and this
probably has a it's only strobing right
now it's like flashing what is it
tell me do it out there trout
wrapping up here everyone thank you so
much for joining like i had a blast
tonight i miss you guys terribly pumped
to be in the discord plump to be part of
this community just want to thank you
all can i trade you a lebron bazooka
slab rookies for seriously maybe digital
i got to look at that come oh
wait i don't see it
oh
let's go
i feel like i'm like i feel weird right
now
i feel i feel high right now
it's a good time i wonder if this is
like buy the empathy 10 pack
anyway i just love being part of this
community missed a lot of you i know
been busy the last couple months
rest assured that we're in it for the
long haul i thank all of you um we are
absolutely focused on getting to the
moon i'm empathetic for a lot of the
conversations on twitter and discord i'm
always compassionate to people's
thoughts on what i should do what i have
to do rest assured i'm working very hard
and thoughtfully i think in long term i
know a lot of people want to flip and
make a quick dollar it's not i can't be
in that business i need to build
something meaningful we're on that focus
with be friends thank you zach i will
try to keep killing it mr chef thank you
um
does this wine go bad if i don't open it
uh p you got some time just like a five
to seven year wine in my opinion great
gift by the way the white's epic mine's
better than i thought it was gonna get
mine's definitely i agree with the
mine's better than was when we tasted
the last yeah
great summer wine
fun conversation piece like the perfect
pool wine of like what is this how do i
get it well you can't get it you know
that kind of fun stuff
fatima great to see you see you justin
i'll see you all in la
living dead here thank you paul i love
the gratitude gorilla in your profile
paul h thank you um great thanksgiving
one
funny enough yeah that's a that's a
great call out actually
yeah it's a great rival for reasons
drink a few next five now drink five at
thanksgiving as an aperitif i agree this
is a great thing that's a good call out
john thank you let's thank john thanks
everyone
um
i'll see you guys in discord
uh i love you jets that's right dial i'm
gonna brandy great to see you steve
lieber great to see you
please join the discord if you're
watching this right now and you're not
part of discord that's insane to me
you're probably on facebook or linkedin
get in there right away
um
uh what's the alcohol beverage on muscat
141 14 1.
um
you're welcome gizellig thank you
gustavo thank you
i'm still huddling too that's awesome
the empathy album is absurd much love
dylan uh i'll buy a 10 pack thank you
andre thank you so much two pack for liz
lily thank you so much 10 pack for
victor p
um
big shout out in taiwan
uh i'll see you sal i can't wait to see
you in l.a brother i love you a lot uh i
hope you're bringing your beautiful
bride
uh i bought two psa 10 jordans
facebook user i just bought two this
week
200k pop baller life
i want to own every psa 10 joint
corner in the market even though i hate
him more than life itself just the best
deal in sports cards and the charizard
hollow shadow listen um
big shout out to tristan hoyt that said
garyvee is a scammer i'll see you in uh
in the hall of fame tristan i can't wait
to see you in heaven we'll have that
discussion
um
i don't buy ungraded cards scott i'll
see you at the national c in l.a
um and i'll see all of you in discord
i'm literally gonna hang up and go home
and talk to all of you on discord that
we're part of this i'd love to get your
feedback i'm literally about to close it
and go in there
and final right hook
garyvee.commoon if you want to be part
of the incredible empathy muscat we'd
love to see you there becon 2023 la
la la la cool kicks 11 a.m to 1 p.m this
sunday i'll see you there
uh by the way this is giving me like
some sort of weird like
can we turn this off jesus christ
um
next week wednesday thursday friday
atlantic city
the national sports card convention
would love to see all of you there
um i know isn't it going i think so oh
man that's awesome nate if you're
watching this please text me if you're
going
uh and then finally if you want to buy
the wine garyvee.com moon
um
i'd love to uh
see you on board with this wine and the
t-shirt
flipped a t-shirt it's like the easy
arbitrage it's only
yeah how many t-shirts are there
because if you broke it up with two yeah
yeah yeah it depends on how they sell
volumes yeah probably two thousand that
could amortize down to eight hundred if
it was only ten of them yeah it's
interesting all right garyvee.com
discord um
love you all hope everyone's well thank
you for the 10 pack by young
money king
it ages really well and this is a seven
year white wine in my opinion based on
residual sugar and acidity yeah
yeah it's going to age well
but more but very honestly like this is
pop and poor late this is labor day wine
everybody here
that has a labor day party that is
either bringing a wine or hosting if
you're bringing wine buy the two pack at
the shirt if you're hosting party buy
the 10-pack and blow everybody away
they're all gonna be like how do i get
this room like you can't and you hold it
and then flip like they're so much fun
sell them a bottle for how much you paid
for the 10 pack
anyway uh we'll see you guys at vcon in
australia 2023 kidding kidding i'm just
trying to razz
but i will be in australia first week of
november details to come the tour is set
first week of november i will be in
australia i'm excited about that
four or five cities you're more than
welcome to come
um
helpful helpful hippo actually eugene
great question so i'm brewing with that
character all right love you guys see ya
you